In this video, we're going to look at configuring your BurpSuite Enterprise Edition web server.
After installation, we recommend setting up the web server URL. This is used by many of the features
in BurpSuite Enterprise, such as when links sent by email are generated and when password reset
links are created. To configure this, go to the settings menu and choose network. Enter either
the fully qualified domain name or IP address of the machine where the web server is installed,
and make sure to include the port number. You can come back and change these settings later on
on standard deployments. If you do change them though, you would need to wait for the web server
to restart and then log in again. If you have a Kubernetes deployment, you cannot change the web
server ports as your external port should be configured as part of your ingress solution setup.
By default, when using the embedded database, the web server is configured to use unencrypted HTTP.
So we recommend enabling TLS for production use so your traffic is encrypted. To do this,
you will need to ensure you have a certificate with a .p12 file extension. Select the use TLS switch
and when prompted upload your certificate. Enter the password for the certificate file
and you also have the option to enable HSTS. If you've already configured your web server URL at the stage
where you enable HTTPS, you will also need to update this in your web server URL.
You can now start using your new settings.